God made me
and that's why
was
the
outcome when you smoke to many drugs.
Allah is
not
so
funny.
Abraham, peace be upon him, God made the
Shia of Ali ibn Abi Talib, may God be pleased with him, and among
his Shia,
God is sister,
before
the verse before it is in
explain itself. This is how you expose this. You know that's why I always advise you to read the Quran. When you
read the Quran, you come to know your lying to you, leading you to these before speaking about peace from Our believing servants. Then We drowned the others. And among his Shia is Abraham. His Shia is Noah,
Abraham,
Noah. Yes, peace be upon him.
Abbas
said
his Shia. The back of some
God
in
God, may God
bless him and grant him peace.
Abraham, Surah An-Nahl. God, then We revealed to you to
follow the religion of Abraham, inclining toward truth. Glory be to God. God, Abraham, peace be upon him. O
God, the Shia.
God, Abraham,
Ali. Glory be to God.
God is the One from whom help is sought. There is no power nor strength except with
God.